it is now time for a very special
ceremonial first pitch
in june of 2019 a young father of two
received life-changing news the
diagnosis of als or as we in the
baseball community know it lou gehrig's
disease it had already taken the lives
of his father two uncles and a cousin
and it seemed would also take the life
of this melrose native within one year
yesterday more than two years later he
turned 40 a milestone that he never
expected to reach
through experimental gene therapy he has
defied the odds he is a beacon of hope
for all those battling als and how happy
we are to welcome him his wife kelsey
and their children cohen and willa to
fenway park this afternoon
won't you please welcome former red sox
beat reporter for the boston globe and
current assistant general manager for
the calgary flames chris snow okay chris
let's see it
right-hander tanner half recalled from
worcester he'll make the start this
afternoon for the red sox owen two on
the year but he's pitched better than
that record just a 2-4-5 era and here's
nelson cruz
who's hitting a 276 with 23 homers
overall but only 186 with four home runs
for tampa bay
2-2 swing and a miss at a slider away a
weak one-hand wave well he had no chance
on that one that retires decided one two
three first for tanner right-hander drew
rasmussen gets the call for the raise he
comes in at one and one he's got a 4-1-5
era he's been a reliever and an opener
last couple of years runner with first
base with nobody out here jaren duran at
212 with a couple of homers left-handed
hitter against the right-handed throwing
rasmus and decent-sized lead at first
for hernandez now the right-hander again
holds to the belt to pitch swaying in a
miss he struck him out nice
again
fastball and duran probably helped him
out in a couple of those swings but
we're glad that he did and there's the
first doubt
brett phillips who had his second grand
slam of the week last night he came in
the ninth inning
one two the count the pitch to the
left-hand batter swung on and missed
another high heater got him
so the single harmless after one and a
half 0-0 with one out in the paces up to
here's jd martinez rasmus again comes to
the set in the pitch
and there is strike three called a good
morning good afternoon
and good night mr martinez and there's
quickly two outs here in the second
and the dangerous mike zenino at the
plate batting just 203 but with 22
homers including one last night here
myers going with a good jump the pitch
swung on and missed the throw is high it
goes into center field kier meyer back
on his feet and he'll go to third
without a throw as duran lobs it back
into second base
so a stolen base for kier meyer and
that'll be a throwing error for sure on
kevin palecki the throw was
way too high well runner at third and
less than two out fly ball hitter
brandon lau coming up
the high fly ball center field duran
coming in
who's going to make the catch and
kermit's coming down the line and the
raves will lead this game
keermeyer scores standing up
he turns that lead off single into a run
plucky to lead things off red sex trail
one nothing third inning no balls in a
strike to plawecky gonzalez and cordero
to follow here comes swinging a drive to
the gap in right center but moving to
his right fighting the sunshine as brett
phillips hunkers down and makes the
catch it will go down to his right knee
marwin gonzalez switch hitter playing
first base today
oh what a pitch right there raise up a
run and now the number nine man frenchie
cordero
and the right hand here in his two-two
pitch swinging at a mess he struck him
out
three straight fastballs at 96 and 97
to blow away cordero and three
no hit innings for drew rashford nelson
cruz here in the fourth inning one
nothing tampa bay cruz whiffed in the
first inning
comes back and gets him though crossfire
cheese see ya strikes out nelson for the
second time wendell growing up in
pennsylvania was a huge fan of
scottie rowland and chase utley
talking about the phillies
tanner wines the 2-2 slider called
strike 3 on the outside corner at the
knees
beautiful pitch a one two three inning
with two strikeouts he's fanned five
two down for rafael devers he's off
wanna pop up to short
that one's stung that's a gapper onto
the grass onto the track it's off to the
triangle
kk runs third he's gonna score easily
down to second denver's and he has tied
the ball game at 1-1 he roped one evers
runs pretty well in scoring position
with two out
for another terrific rbi man at jd
martinez rasmussen's pitch grounded
along third backhanded by wendell now
he's got it and the long throw in time
side is retired and rasmussen gets out
of it with a tie
diaz with a base hit in the second oh
nicely done down he goes hacking that's
what i'm talking about one two three
don't mess around with this ball stuff
now phillips who struck out his first
time up one two swinging a miss
pitch down and away a splitter there
getting a strike out that's number seven
here's zanino now he struck out his
first time up kenny doesn't go and it's
a swing and a miss strike three blew him
away with a high heater at 94. punch out
number eight wander in the game today is
five to left and he is grounded back to
the mound
the 3-2
into center field well hit duran's going
to turn around look up and that ball is
high off the wall i think it was to the
left
of that yellow stripe
bronco thought it was gone
but and it but it bounced over the fence
you think about it left and then bounces
over the fence and they're calling it a
home run
it's a home run
a two run home run for wander franco
wow and the rays take a three to one
lead here meyer already two for two
coming up oh a ball call
by hunter wendelstadt and they're going
to get another run looking at a replay
of the bach
and i think what threw him off is
plawecki with his right hand made a
circular motion as if to say i'm going
to go through the signs again
clear buck
another walk pure meyer here's zanino
robles comes set at the letters
his one-two pitch swinging a miss at a
high fastball he struck him out
to end the inning but the race and nine
men to the plate they bat around they
scored three times
jackson rios against manuel margot and
then kim iron cenino
here comes swinging a fly ball to center
field should be more than deep enough
duran is back and under it coming in to
make the catch tagging third window he
will score as the throw goes to second
and margot with a sacrifice fly and the
rays have a 5-1 lead in the eighth and
the infield back in for mike cenino on
the pitch long drive to deep left field
way up into the lights and it's a
three-run home run to maybe seal this
one
it went up over the monster and headed
for the caskin flagon a monstrous
three-run homer by mike cenino and the
rays have an eight-to-one lead in boston
here's brandon lau he's got one for two
with an rbi today
tagged in the left center duran back to
the track all the way back leaping and
he's got it makes the catch at the 379
mark but no one
could catch zuninos of course the
three-run blast rafael devers
will get another opportunity now the o2
pitch
from sheriff after a pause on its way
strike three cold game over
rafael devers gets rung up and the rays
come into fenway park and take two out
of three
and leave with a bigger lead than what
they had when they had coming in